what's going on guys this is Robin and
it's weird I have all this all this
equipment in front of my face I feel
like a board from Star Trek or something
like that it's just you know like I'm
get ready just like mount up you know
and just recharge myself but as you guys
can see I have a whole new setup I've
got all kinds of cool stuff I mean I've
got well I had a blue Yeti microphone
before but now I've got like a boom arm
and a shock mount and a pop filter and
and all kinds of stuff so hopefully the
audio sounds a great deal better than it
had before I don't think it sounded
terrible before but you know as you guys
know I'm trying to bring you guys the
best stuff that I can and so I figure
you know why not upgrade to a whole new
setup they could improve my audio much
better than it was before and to make it
sound better the downside is that with
these video blogs it's just like a
mountain of stuff in my face as there's
all kinds of things here so what's up
but anyway so I just want to give you
guys a shout out and to say hey and say
that we've we've reached like 4,000
subscribers now I think we're actually
in excess I think we're almost we're
approaching 40 100 which is crazy i mean
this is this is absolutely nuts but
there seem to be like a really a lot of
positive feedback on on black panther a
lot of you guys really seem to enjoy the
character of two chawla in the video
that i did with him on here on youtube
so i really appreciate that i'm glad you
guys really enjoyed it also I've heard
your all's requests I've heard you guys
talking and you guys say that you want
to see a video on Deadpool so i will do
a video on Deadpool it'll actually be a
little while before I can do a video
just because work is work as nuts as you
guys know I have a full-time job so my
full-time job takes priority and my
cat's meow and I don't know why but my
full-time job takes priority and you
know when when I have time you know I
try to make these videos and all the
free time that I have now hopefully a
time will come when I can like leave my
job and do this full time but until then
you know I try to fit in time do the
videos where I can so you know maybe
it's two hours here two hours there you
know there's been times where I've got
off work at 11pm and stayed up until
like you know five or six o'clock in the
morning working on a video
you know trying to make sure that it's
that it's top-notch stuff so because of
the fact that the month of May this
month is going to be so chaotic and
because we have two guys that are taken
off it's going to be really difficult to
crank out videos so we might only see
you know four or five videos this month
so again I apologize for that you know
I'd love to upload a lot more but um you
know it's going to be tough it's going
to be difficult just because you know
work is getting in the way but any event
so we so yeah just just want to touch
base with you guys just want to say hey
I just want to say thanks and so you
guys are fantastic you guys are number
one in my book you know you guys are
awesome and hopefully we continue to
grow we continue to thrive and continue
to become better at um you know at what
it is that we're doing and and yeah let
me know what you guys think about the
audio let me go let me know if you guys
think the audio sounds better than it
did before if it sounds about the same
if you guys can't really tell a
difference but again you know I think
that this will go towards making the
video sound more professional and it'll
make the video sound clear and and
easier to understand in terms of what it
is that I'm saying so with that being
said I will catch you guys later peace